hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in republic' book
2 Glaucon continues his arguments
against socrates position of justice
that justice is something good to ya for
its own sake what we call an intrinsic
good as opposed to instrumental good and
he's actually playing devil's advocate
here Walken himself doesn't buy this
position but is saying look a lot of
people say this sort of thing and I want
to get your response to this socrates
because if I'm I'm going to get a good
response from anyone it's probably going
to be from you so he says look I'm going
to tell you what I think or what other
people think the origin and the nature
of justice is and they're gonna in
essence say that justice is something
like an arrangement that we come to it's
not something valuable for its own sake
it's only valuable because it keeps a
certain kind of order or predictability
or you know safety security something
like that and this is one of the early
expressions of any type of moral theory
that we call contract Arianism or
sometimes it's framed in terms of
contract theory you find a lot of other
people in the ancient world expressing
similar sentiments so Plato is really
grappling with something which he
doesn't buy it by the way he doesn't
accept he doesn't think this is really
the case but is a prevalent view
something that is an important contender
to take into account so how does this
begin well Glaucon says by nature they
say to commit and justice is a good and
a suffer it is an evil so when you have
injustice taking place what do we mean
by injustice well we mean things like
lying right if you lie with somebody
you're getting over on them you're
you're getting out of something that you
ought to do not taking responsibility
for something you might be manipulating
that there's a lot of different
possibilities there but the basic idea
is you're not doing the right thing and
you're doing something that gives you an
undue advantage over them
stealing would be another example of
injustice right you do steal your
keeping your stuff and you're taking
somebody else's stuff
killing somebody to be a matter of
injustice you know provided there's no
reason for you to do it's not
self-defense
you know executing a criminal or
something like that but you're just
killing somebody
well you're committing injustice you're
taking away their life and you know
let's say you were a sadist you actually
got a kick out of that you would be
getting some benefit to yourself game
with the pleasure in which you feel a
lot of it humiliating somebody else
committing what the Greeks called the
hubris wants an insult play notice I'm
talking about this quite so much but
Aristotle says when somebody commits
hubris they're actually trying to push
the other person into a subservient
position to make them feel ashamed and
why do I do that because it makes them
feel good it gives them pleasure
it's
you know it's gonna be discussed as the
desire to dominate later on well that's
a case where again injustice is
committed the doer receives some sort of
good the software receives some sort of
ban out of it you could think of a lot
of other examples cheating on a spouse
you know the person who does it gets to
have extra sexual pleasure
maybe they enjoy breaking rules the
sufferer feels pain as a result right
they the relationship was broken they
made me feel like a fool or something
along those lines so to commit injustice
is a good to suffer it is an evil and
why do people get upset about this then
well there there's an excess there's
more evil more bad than there is good so
if you have a situation in which you
might say everybody's got an equal
chance to either commit wrong or to
suffer wrong they're going to look more
at the bad side of it that could accrue
to that if they happen to suffer more
it's almost a lot like rational choice
theory where you're saying you know all
of the things being equal I don't know
where I'm going to end up I'm going to
be on the short end of the stick or the
good end of the stick if I wind up on
the you know good end of the stick that
works out well for me but it could work
out much worse for me if I
on the bad so the rational thing to do
in a case like that is to say well we're
not going to let anybody do this we're
going to make sure that everybody
observes justice in relation to each
other so he says when men do wrong and
are wronged by another and taste of both
so it's not a purely hypothetical thing
it's a you realize that man I don't like
it when other people screw me over and
I'm not getting as much of screwing them
over as other people are you know
imposing on me it doesn't pay off that
well those who lack the power to avoid
the one and take the other determine
that it's for their benefit to make a
compact or a contract or an agreement to
neither commit nor suffer injustice he
says this is the beginning of
legislation
legislation society all of this comes
out of this experience of man I don't
like getting screwed over and I'm not
getting as much fun or enjoyment or good
spring other people over as I'm
suffering when I get screwed over myself
but so it's better if nobody screws
anybody else or it's better if nobody
commits injustice and that's what
legislation and covenants is supposed to
do this he says is the beginning of that
legislation and covenants between men
and that they name the commandment of
the law the waffle will adjust that's
the genesis and essential nature of
justice a compromise between the best
what is the best to commit injustice
without suffering it what is the worst
to suffer injustice without getting to
commit it in turn what's the middle
point justice it's a Midway this is
midway between the two it's accepted and
approved not he has a real good that is
something that's desirable for its own
sake but desirable so that you can make
sure that this doesn't happen to you
that's the essential social contract
idea of Justices it's you know human
beings by nature are likely to try to
get over on each other too too you know
tilt the scales to make things work out
better for themselves at the expense of
somebody else and it's the the fact that
there's a reversibility involved here
that if I can do that to somebody else
they can do that to me and that makes me
vulnerable to the same kind of harm as I
might impose on other people that makes
me say oh I don't know I don't I don't
like that I'm going to be a good guy and
I want everybody else to be good guys
too so we have a system then in which
each person displays justice towards
each other and that
they break that system if they step out
of that if they try to assert themselves
above somebody else if they turn it into
a merely one way to think then you get
rid of that person you apply the justice
system to you know if you find them
guilty of the breach of some sort and
you say okay you don't you don't get to
stay in our society
maybe you kill them exile them you do
something like that
so he says justice is not a real good
but a thing honored in the lack of vigor
to do injustice anybody who had the
power to do it and was in reality a man
like you know somebody who was very
assertive somebody who's dominant would
never make a contact with anyone either
to wrong them they're to be wrong for he
would be man so if you had an individual
who actually said it's a strong person
that strong person that gets to do
injustice to everybody and actually it
would make sense for them to keep
doesn't talk that much about this but it
would make sense for them in a society
to keep you know some sort of set of
rules and regulations in play but he
would he or she would get to decide you
know holler apply and they wouldn't
apply to that person right this would be
essentially what the Greeks called the
tyranny of one person rule where it
could be an Oleg Archy where you have
the you know the rich or the literally
the few of the Holy Ghost decide what
they're going to do and everybody else
is subject to them everybody else has to
observe justice but they don't have to
observe justice towards other people so
he says the nature of that of justice is
this and such as this Socrates and such
are the conditions in which it
originates according to the theory so
the idea is that the reason why we have
systems of justice is is only that we
want to keep other people including
these these potentially powerful
individuals who
you know abuse us and use the rules just
to consolidate their own power and maybe
you know work them to their own
advantage we want to keep people like
that out so what do we need to do you're
rid of any people like that these are
the people that are doing injustice and
we make everybody follow the same set of
rules if anybody gets out of line then
we you know punish them in some way now
notice what does this mean there's
nothing there about justice within the
person justice is something that exists
only in the relationship between people
right even this notion of injustice over
here is not something that's in the doer
and then yeah you know maybe even in the
sufferer in a certain way it's something
that's in the relationship between them
it's external it's and extrinsic to the
the person involved so the just person
is not a person in whom there is justice
and then they behave justly towards
other people it's just somebody who
happens to meet this set of criteria
that keeps social order that preserves
the peace between them so in a situation
like this in a view like this there's
not going to be any attention to moral
development there's not going to be any
focus on the goodness of justice for its
own sake as a matter of fact everybody's
sort of in the know about the fact that
hey if if we could break the rules and
get away with it we would so this is a
contract area understanding of justice
that Glaucon is putting forth again he
doesn't buy this he doesn't believe it
neither does Plato they're putting it
out there as a theory that they want to
have in full light so that they can
bad so they're taking him up with
something better